have you seen the pictures have you seen
the pictures of him with the crack pipe
did john ryden have unfortunately i
can't show them to you right now but
this is the hard drive they're on right
there
oh my word you know him you love him he
is america's mayor and he is the top dog
in the news right now
uh former mayor of new york city and
times magazine man
of the year uh and i call him i would
like to say friend but he's been on the
show once but
mayor giuliani how are you sir how are
you zen
i am doing fine thank you very much so
uh seems like you're a busy man these
days
i'd say so yeah i'm busy but it's it's
good we're
finally getting the truth out yeah
taking a while but we're finally
well we'll get to that in a second not
getting it out as much as
one could if not for you know today's
roman empire which is big tech but
before we go into
the hunter biden emails and all of that
uh what do you expect from each town
hall
tonight and of course by the way sorry i
should have mentioned uh the the podcast
is common sense available at
rudyscommonsense.com i'm sorry i figured
people know you have a podcast but it's
common sense
with rudy giuliani what do you expect
tonight from the town halls
first donald trump than uh joseph biden
well i mean donald trump has done so
many of them i think we all know
what's going to happen he'll be he'll be
very transparent he's got
tremendous command to the issues the
substantive issues
um he'll answer the questions directly
he's not going to not going to say you
don't deserve to know
my position on whatever
which biden is likely to say whatever is
kind of a placeholder but it works in
this instance because
it has been pretty much used for
whatever well i mean
it'll be uh biden who knows what we're
going to get with biden i don't know if
he's
taken a sufficient number of drugs i
guess he'll get through it if he hasn't
he'll forget the pledge of allegiance do
you pledge allegiance to the flag yeah
you know
right whatever uh do you okay we'll move
that's that's kind of
you just threw some bombs out there like
you threw like it was a molotov cocktail
at a uh at a peaceful protest
do you really think that former vice
president joe biden is using performance
enhancing drugs and obviously this is
conjecture but if you had to bet
yeah okay
i think he's taking something like
adderall to help his concentration
because there are times in which he
wanders off into who knows where
and there are other times where he's
pretty focused and i mean i've spoken to
doctors about it including a podcast i
did on it
both doctors said that from everything
they can see
he looks like he's pretty far advanced
with dementia
um some of the some of the prime
symptoms being he gets numbers screwed
up
he gets lost in the middle of sentences
he can't remember who his wife is
he thinks he was in the center for 186
years he thinks he's running for the
senate
well he said the other day i'm running
for the senate he didn't even pause i
mean it's like
yeah we we might make that mistake i'm
running for the senate no no
right you know i'm running for the
senate i was in the center for
years you'd think there'd be a forehead
slap somewhere along the
president
[Laughter]
but by how how amazing would it be if
this was all one brilliant ploy just to
convince his wife that i didn't know
she wasn't you i forgot who you are you
saw me do it on a national stage
i think it's going to be an insanity
defense in his rico case
right okay so let's get to this this is
uh i have to ask you some
some questions that obviously people
want to see ask both from the right and
the left but
cermai's here for people who don't know
because a lot of people get their
information from facebook and twitter
and the story uh was throttled we tested
it by the way
it was the first time i think it was
ever retweeted by the the president we
tested
uh the new york post article about your
hunter buying emails and it told us that
it could not be posted we have the
screenshot available on my twitter
because it violated their uh their
policies
and then it was sort of disseminated and
jack dorsey apologized he'll have to
speak before hearing
so for people who haven't heard yet this
is a bombshell in new york post
uh what is it if you have to give them
the bullet points hunter biden joe biden
what's the implication here hunter biden
uh and joe biden are involved in a
bribery scheme
in in ukraine and hunter biden and joe
have
for years said that joe knew nothing
about barisma the company that paid the
bribe
uh that he he knew nothing about his
dealings in
in ukraine and what what there is is a
cold clear uh group of text messages in
which hunter biden sets up a meeting
for the number two person in that
company with joe biden
right who then checks hunted back and
thanks him so it makes joe a complete
liar for the last seven years
it shows that he met with bharisma um
i think he um it's not on his public
schedule
but we have another one where uh hunter
biden was snuck into the back of the
state department so he's meeting with
the deputy secretary of state
tony blinken isn't reported because if
he had the meeting
it would have violated the foreign
agents registration act
so they i mean there are plenty of um
very very damning things with regard to
ukraine on the on the hard drive the
main one being that
joe biden's been lying for seven years
about it and knew all about
uh barista as as as you knew was true
what you got to do
anything about my son's foreign dealings
how credible is that
right the guy is suffering from really
massive drug addiction
which the hard drive will make clear
it's hard to get through
a line of photographs without seeing one
of him with a cracked pipe
sitting in a carpet well he was a fan of
weezer in the closet
going bonkers he's like a zombie have
you seen the fingers
have you seen the pictures of him with
the crack pipe did john right i have
oh wow does he look at least look like
cool
unfortunately i can't show them to you
right now but this is the hard drive
they're on
oh my word let me ask you this mayor
giuliani
how did you get that hard drive because
this is this is the crux of the new york
the new york post article being
throttled right on social media they
said that you've been working with a
russian
agent uh or that it's entirely false
actually i got it directly from
you are putin going to believe who likes
hash pipe
again putin sent it to me and he said um
i don't even know he actually just
wanted a couple of bottles of vodka in
return
which wasn't bad i mean it cost me about
150 bucks i sent it to putin
right and um if you send him something
better than great goose he'll show you
the heroine
there with the crack pipes it's got him
there
uh doing an imitation of anthony weiner
about 50 times
um you know what i'm talking about right
it's got some very disturbing things on
it that i shouldn't joke about
and here's how i got it hunter biden
brought his hard drive into a repairman
to repair it the repairman took it
hunter biden signed a receipt for it
which i have here
uh and said he would have to if you're
going to come back for it
two days later he came back and gave him
a part and then when it was done
he never came back according to the
agreement
after 90 days the hard drive is
abandoned
under the law and it belongs to the
merchant
the merchant held it for another three
four months and then he heard all this
talk on television
and and he started to get worried what
do i have here this could be criminal
evidence
right so he opened he opened it and he
almost fainted
he said i know i never saw anything like
this before
the uh and if you looked at the if you
look at the photographs
you'd probably come to that conclusion
also but then he took a look at the text
and he saw her in the text
major contradictions to what the bidens
were saying on television like
like the one i just told you right biden
was saying i didn't know anything about
barista in ukraine there's plenty of
evidence that he could can i ask you a
question mayor giuliani because
you know you mentioned anthony weiner
and you know i sort of came up under
andrew breitbart
before it was breitbart it was big
hollywood and i was there for the wiener
scandal and acorn and all that here's my
question to you because
obviously you know that the left is
going to come out and say well this
can't be corroborated that's the basis
on which facebook and twitter have
throttled this story despite the fact
that they were covering stories that
were verifiably false regarding
trump calling the troops luck suckers
and losers
but how do you um how do you go about
them behind the scenes
making sure that new york post or have
you offered any evidence to anyone other
than new york post to corroborate
because
obviously new york post believes that
this is real
they've confirmed it but is there any
way for you to get the media to confirm
it behind the scenes
so that we don't run a follow social
media or do they not care
if if they think it's not correct so
rupert murdoch
you don't i mean he he had it for five
days
and they did everything they could to
verify it they're convinced that it's
real
not only that i internally verified it i
i there are there are things on that
hard drive that only hunter biden would
know
because those things were given to us by
uh anonymous informants dates for
example that aren't public
dates of meetings that were never
recorded in the state department of the
white house
in order to hide them and the hard drive
comes up with exactly those same dates
that would only have been known to
hunter biden uh his pictures all over it
make it pretty clear that it's him
his signature is on the receipt for it
uh the gentleman can identify him as
hunter biden
uh and if you read if you read the
intern if you read the internal
uh messages they're quite consistent
with what we already know
it describes the transaction uh
describes a transaction in china that i
think we all know it's in
schweiker's book almost exactly the same
as schweicher
does it except it explains that uh when
the
money was transferred the ukraine thing
is
exactly what the five witnesses told me
all of whom want to come to the united
states and testify
under oath and are being blocked from
coming to the united states
and um i mean this is really ridiculous
i mean this is mammoth obviously like
this makes this makes water
gate look like uh what do we say dwarf
piss droplets at this point
it's so huge that it almost seems um
almost for lack of a better word it
almost it almost sounds unbelievable to
americans because like well this
this is so huge and that's why twitter
and facebook have decided to throttle it
which
hopefully at this point we understand
that this is now a first amendment issue
and not a free speech version of the
first amendment issue but we're talking
about actually the freedom
of the press if new york post is not
being allowed to get their material up
there one thing i wanted to
make sure you and you may not know how
to explain this because it's more of a
tech issue
your story obviously or the story the
new york post story that you've
obviously provided information on
was not available when we were searching
at social media uh
all across platforms what was was a
story
that claimed you or someone who worked
with you
had photoshopped these files or had
fabricated them so that wasn't
considered fake news
that was at the top and that's not even
the claim they're making yeah as a
matter of fact i have my
guy bryce here i'm willing to invite i i
mean i just invited uh
someone on fox if they want to come here
and look at it they can't take it away
but
you come and look at it work around for
yourself well i actually have my tech
guy bryce here who explained to me why
those articles were false right off the
bat if i may
and you were saying that there's
something so it's not super you know
super definitive
right but it's just an explanation yeah
uh
gibbon you want to pull up the uh raster
verse vector
thing okay so just we'll explain it
really quickly because
yeah so their argument was that the
little logo was
pixelized and all kind of low resolution
compared to the text
but uh that's that's kind of what would
happen if you exported
an email okay yeah uh
so vector so so the little icon is
usually like an apple
or a google type image right and that's
probably referencing either a vector
or higher resolution images on the
server okay it sounded like
a major exactly what happened this is
this was an older
this was an older the original hard
drive was older
and he had to put it on newer hard
drives i mean he can explain it
in detail and and and come on let's face
it
they're not challenging the accuracy of
well they're not anymore
in fact i'll give you something that
really verifies it the very morning this
came out within about 20 minutes
hunter biden's lawyer called the
merchant
and asked him if he could have the hard
drive back really
yeah well that's uh yeah that also
reminds me i need to call geek
you can leave bryce yeah i'm talking
with america's mayor i apologize for
that he was
he um that is now is that is there any
record of that in other words like
the lawyer reaching out to this man i
would imagine yeah yeah
there's he actually did it by uh
telephone and by email we have the email
good luck it's almost as though it makes
it worse on them especially
the dumbest thing a lawyer can do but
who says this
would you advise me with the dumbest kid
in law school
if someone came to you
dumbest kid in our law school class but
he's a nice guy
he cheated his way through oh my
plagiarized and lost
all right well mr uh mayor giuliani we
uh we're gonna have to get going here
pretty soon but let me ask you is there
uh what else can we expect obviously the
relations now with china and the
leverage that
china could have on a joe biden
presidency uh came out today
what else do you think peop is going to
most surprise people since
you're kind of this is a drip drip from
this hard drive what is there something
can you give us
i think i think uh i think as the second
transaction in
china comes out you're going to see him
being involved with a
chinese communist operative an
intelligence operative and it's quite
obvious that he's setting him up he's
setting hunter biden up and he's setting
joe up for extortion
um i think there'll be more emails and
text messages that make that clear i
think you're gonna see
more emails and text messages that
describe
how joe was compensated how he was
getting a portion of this money
in fact he was getting a large portion
of this money and
it'll explain also how joe biden who
never really made much money
has two or three very very luxurious
homes
right because he didn't pay for anything
hunter did so
um this is a long-term bribery scheme
that started at a low level in delaware
with his brother james
selling his office holding the money
taking care of joe
and when they got to the big time they
shook down iraq for
i think about 500 million
ukraine for about 20 china i don't know
i mean 30 40 million
right oh oh oh gosh i missed russia the
3.5 million from the
mayor's wife who was a good friend by
the way we're kidding around about putin
that woman is a close ally of putin so
we have the irony that
we the president was accused of falsely
of colluding with
russia but biden actually got paid by
russia well
i'll give you one more when the media or
you know i say media but i'm talking
about twitter and facebook but let's be
honest that's what the media really is
now i don't watch cable
news anymore because my doctor told me
it was a hypochondriac that i didn't
have mesothelioma so i went
just to social at that point i'm sure
but i need i need a reverse mortgage doc
he's like don't listen to tom selleck it
actually is his first rodeo
but um my question to you
here is um this is unbelievable when you
think about the fact that they fact
checked this not fact check said well we
can't verify the source but you just
mentioned russia
people forget there was a story about
donald trump washing russian prostitutes
peeing on furniture
and there was no verification and none
of that was ever throttled so
um i am really looking forward and he's
a germaphobe
i've known him 30 years i knew that was
false the day they said it
he wouldn't get within 10 miles or
something like that
unless like beforehand he had his
assistants go in like greeks and put the
cellophane back over the furniture and
he would still be like oh
gross no i didn't buy it either um the
show is common sense it's the podcast
available at rudy's commonsense.com
you can follow uh mayor giuliani at rudy
giuliani
on the twitter uh as long as they still
allow him
i really appreciate you doing this and
uh i know you're staking your reputation
day by day now on twitter
okay okay well thank you so much uh may
giuliani we really appreciate it and uh
i'll be uh keeping everyone abreast and
talk with you soon you're a lot of fun
thank you god bless hey there youtube
viewer if you like this video click one
of these other videos playing in a box
subscribe hit the notification bell you
may be wondering why after this
outlandish video this is such a straight
end card that's because we've recently
learned that end cards actually
determine the youtube algorithm as it
relates to controversy on a sliding
scale
so we have a yellow and it escalates all
the way to the word